THE PENNSYLVANIA DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR BOB CASEY.
SENATOR, VERY GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
THIS EVENT IN PENNSYLVANIA
UNDERSCORES YET ANOTHER
REMINDER OF HOW IMPORTANT
PENNSYLVANIA AND ITS 20
ELECTORAL VOTES ARE, AND I’M
JUST WONDERING, POST THE DEBATE
AND THE DUST-UP OVER WHAT JOE
BIDEN WAS SAYING EVENTUALLY
PHASING OUT THE OIL INDUSTRY, I
KNOW HE’S PUT IT BACK TO 2050,
AND FRACKING, BUT THE PRESIDENT
STATES THAT HE WANTS TO KILL
JOBS IN STATES LIKE YOURS.
IS IT RESONATING WITH
PENNSYLVANIANS?
>> I THINK THE RECORD IS CLEAR,
IT’S CLEAR FROM WHAT JOE BIDEN
HAS SAID OVER AND OVER AGAIN,
AND WHAT I KNOW TO BE THE
TRUTH, WHICH IS HE DOESN’T
SUPPORT A BAN ON FRACKING, BUT
WHAT HE WANTS TO DO IS MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO IT THE WAY THAT
IT SHOULD BE DONE LIKE IT’S
DONE IN PENNSYLVANIA, WHERE
IT’S DONE IN COMPLIANCE WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS AND
RULES SO YOU’RE NOT POLLUTING
PEOPLE’S WATER, THEIR GROUND
WATER, THEIR DRINKING WATER,
AND POLLUTING THE ENVIRONMENT,
BUT I THINK THAT RECORD IS
PRETTY CLEAR.
I KNOW THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
TRYING TO MUDDY THE WATER, NOT
TO OVERUSE THE ANALOGY, BUT I
THINK IT’S PRETTY CLEAR TO
PEOPLE.
I THINK AT THE SAME TIME, A LOT
OF PEOPLE IN OUR STATE THAT
KNOW THAT WE’VE GOT TO CONFRONT
THE CHALLENGE OF CLIMATE CHANGE
AND DEAL WITH IT AND I THINK
THAT’S--
>> WHAT HE SAID, SENATOR, WHEN
I SAID, I WANT TO TRANSITION
FROM THE OIL INDUSTRY AND TRIED
TO CLARIFY, I’VE ALWAYS SAID, I
DON’T KNOW WHAT’S SURPRISING
PEOPLE.
OBVIOUSLY, A BIG ENERGY
FRACKING STATE.
ARE THEY ON BOARD WITH THE
NOTION THEY’RE GOING TO
TRANSITION AWAY FROM IT.
IF I’M A YOUNG WORKER AND
LOOKING FOR A JOB IN THAT
INDUSTRY AND I’M HEARING A
POTENTIAL PRESIDENT SAY THAT
IT’S GOING TO START PHASING
OUT, THERE DOESN’T SEEM TO BE
MUCH OF A FUTURE IN IT SO I
MIGHT LOOK ELSEWHERE.
>> I THINK THERE’S A FUTURE IN
IT BECAUSE IN OUR STATE,
FRACKING NOT ONLY PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR JOB GROWTH AND
CONTINUED STABILITY IN THE JOB
MARKET AND A LOT OF EMPLOYMENT,
BUT MAKES US LESS DEPENDENT ON
MIDDLE EAST OIL.
SO IT’S BEEN A GREAT BENEFIT
BOTH IN AN ENERGY SENSE AS WELL
AS A JOB SENSE.
JOE BIDEN IS GOING TO WORK HARD
TO PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE STILL HAVE
THOSE JOBS THAT COME FROM GAS
EXTRACTION.
BUT
BUT, NEIL--
NO, I UNDERSTAND THAT, BUT HE
ALSO ADDRESSED, SENATOR THE
NOTION OF TAKING AWAY SUBSIDIES
FOR THE INDUSTRY, I MEAN, TO
HEAR THAT IN A STATE LIKE YOURS
OR FOR SUCH A BIG EMPLOYER, IS
THAT GOING TO HURT HIM?
ARE PEOPLE GOING TO HEAR THAT
AND SAY I KNOW HE’S LOW
EMISSION, ENERGY AND ALL THAT,
I KNOW HE’S FOR CLEANER FUELS
AND ALL THAT, I JUST DIDN’T
KNOW, YOU KNOW, OW ANTI HE WAS
ALL THAT WE’RE DOING.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THIS?
>> NEIL, I THINK IT’S PRETTY
CLEAR AND MOST PEOPLE IN
PENNSYLVANIA ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT TWO FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES,
RIGHT?
THE VIRUS AND JOBS AND THE
ECONOMY, BOTH OF WHICH ARE
INTERRELATED.
WE CAN’T RECOVER FULLY UNTIL WE
TACKLE THE VIRUS, THAT’S WHY
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
CANDIDATES.
THE PRESIDENT STILL DOESN’T
HAVE A VIRUS PLAN, NO PLAN TO
TACKLE THE VIRUS, NO PLAN TO
CREATE GOOD PAYING JOBS.
JOE BIDEN IS GOING TO BE IN
LUZERNE COUNTY TODAY AND THAT
COUNTY JUST THE LAST MONTHLY
NUMBER 18,000 PEOPLE OUT OF
WORK, 12% UNEMPLOYMENT AND
ALMOST 28,000 PEOPLE WILL LOSE
THEIR HEALTH CARE IN THEY GET
THEIR WAY ON DESTROYING THE
AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE ACT.
AND WHEN PEOPLE IN LUZERNE
COUNTY AND THINKING ABOUT THE
STATEWIDE ELECTION, THEY’RE
THINKING ABOUT TACKLE THE VIRUS
AND THE JOBS PLAN.
JOE BIDEN HAS GOT BOTH AND I
THINK THAT’S WHY HE’S AHEAD.
NEIL: WE HAVEN’T SEEN ANY POLLS
POST THE DEBATE COMMENTS.
AND IT COULD BE A LOST WORSE IF
THE ENERGY INDUSTRY IN YOUR
STATE, IN THAT COUNTY IS
WALLOPED, RIGHT.
HOW DOES HE ADDRESS THAT?
WHAT DO YOU THINK HE DOES?
>> BUT, NEIL, THAT UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE IN LUZERNE COUNTY IN
PENNSYLVANIA AND IN AMERICA
COULD BE A LOT BETTER IF THE
PRESIDENT GOT SERIOUS ABOUT
TACKLING THE VIRUS.
I HAD ONE QUESTION FOR THE
PRESIDENT ON THE VIRUS.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER, WOULD
DONALD TRUMP HAVE GOTTEN THE
CORONAVIRUS IF PRESIDENT TRUMP
DID A BETTER JOB TACKLING THE
VIRUS?
WE’VE GOT A--
WE NEED A STRATEGY, NEIL, TO
PUT THIS VIRUS BEHIND US.
WE SHOULD BE AHEAD ON THAT AND
WE SHOULD BE FURTHER DOWN THE
ROAD OF CREATING MILLIONS OF
GOOD PAYING JOBS.
JOE BIDEN’S GOT A PLAN.
NEIL: OVER A HUNDRED COUNTRIES
HAVE IT AND THE PRESIDENT OF
POLAND, THE LEADER OF GREAT
BRITAIN.
IT SEEMS TO HAVE RECKLESS
ABANDON WHO IT TARGETS, IT’S
ACROSS THE GLOBE.
CAN YOU REALLY BLAME THE
PRESIDENT FOR THAT, ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU LOOK AT DEATH RATES,
WHICH IS TRAGICALLY, A METRIC
YOU SHOULD CONSIDER, PER
100,000 U.S. IS 11TH--
THE U.S. IS 11TH ON THAT LIST.
I’M NOT MINIMIZING THE DEATHS,
NOT MINIMIZING EVERYTHING
THAT’S HAPPENED, BUT ON A PER
CAPITA BASIS THERE ARE
COUNTRIES ON THIS PLANET, A LOT
WORSE.
>> NEIL, I THINK HERE ARE
IMPORTANT NUMBERS ON DEATHS AND
CASES.
FOUR IN 20.
WE’VE GOT 4% OF THE WORLD’S
POPULATION, 19 TO 20% OF THE
DEATHS AND THAT NUMBER HAS BEEN
PRETTY STEADY AND A LITTLE
HIGHER, 20, 21% OF THE CASES IN
THE WORLD.
JUST ON THAT ALONE, IT’S CLEAR
THAT WE ARE NOT WHERE WE NEED
TO BE.
LOOK, I LIVE IN NORTHEASTERN
PENNSYLVANIA, ONE COUNTY OVER
FROM LUZERNE COUNTY, I’M IN
LACKAWANNA, OUR CASE NUMBERS
ARE GOING UP IN THESE COUNTIES,
GOING UP STATEWIDE.
WE HAVE TO TACKLE THE VIRUS AND
IT WOULD BE GREAT FOR THE
COUNTRY IF THE PRESIDENT WORE A
MASK ALL THE TIME, I COULD GIVE
HIM ONE THAT SAYS VOTE ON IT
AND TACKLE THE VIRUS EVERY DAY.
EVERYONE WOULD BE BETTER OFF.
HE COULD AFFECT THE BEHAVIOR OF
TENS OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
IF MORE PEOPLE WERE WEARING THE
MASK AND TAKING IT SERIOUSLY.
WE COULD PUT THE VIRUS BEHIND
US AND FULLY RECOVER.
NEIL: WE’LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.